this road leads right into the war the
intersection near Pope asthma is scarred
by the heavy fighting it has witnessed
the OSCE mission regularly sends
observers to note any breaches of the
Minsk agreement but this morning things
are relatively quiet Ukrainian soldiers
take us to the frontline this unit has
been stationed in a forest near Pope
Asma for six weeks now the commander
says he's glad they haven't lost any men
yet just across from them no-man's land
this so-called gray zone is a
demilitarized area but despite its name
shots continued to be fired at Ukrainian
soldiers the room hear the sound of
gunfire echoes across the frozen fields
the platoon leader calls this front
music he says the separatists aren't
observing the ceasefire the other side
is trying to provoke us so that we open
fire at them but we stay still and they
shoot the OSCE says the Ukrainians have
also been breaking the ceasefire but the
military denies this only when the life
or well-being of our soldiers is in
danger that's when we give the orders to
fire but if this is the case we only use
weapons allowed by the Minsk agreement
on this day the Ukrainian military has
already counted 37 violations of the
ceasefire the independent OSCE report is
not yet available for eastern Ukraine
this is the third winter at war all
efforts to revitalize the so-called
minced peace process ended in a deadlock
Ukraine and Russian backed separatists
cannot agree upon a roadmap how to bring
peace to the embattled region for the
soldiers in the trenches this is a
static battle in a frozen conflict